hi I am Ken Jeong and this is the wired
autocomplete interview thank you so much
for feeding the beast that is my
Hollywood ego is Ken Jong who is Ken
Jong's wife well my wife's name is Tran
ho she kept her last name for comedy
reasons she's Vietnamese doctor last
name ho
I married a ho and get away with
anything get in the car ho make me some
rice ho and you complete me home and
scene if Ken Jong Chinese no Ken Jeong
is Korean
it is ken Jeong a real doctor yes I was
a real physician and general
practitioner internal medicine and I was
fortunate enough to create a show called
doctor Ken which was based on my life as
a real life physician yes Kim Jong it's
ken Jeong in the movie real genius no I
was not in real genius although I loved
that movie that that was that was
literally I think 40 years ago
unfortunately I was not in the movie
real genius because I am a real genius
okay very good we're onto the W's what
ken Jeong what was Ken Jong's first
movie a very very fortunate my first
movie was knocked up and that was
written directed by Judd Apatow and it
had Seth Rogen Katherine Heigl anybody
who is anybody in comedy was in knocked
up and had Paul Rudd Craig Robinson
Adam Scott this is right off the top of
my head Jonah Hill Jay Baruchel Jason
Segel Kristen Wiig Bill Hader it was
like The Avengers of comedy and that was
my first movie knocked up really opened
the doors for me and I I really do owe
so much to Judd Apatow what does Ken
Jeong do for a living well as you know I
overact but I also do PR appearances and
overacting and press are my passions I
also like to act
occasionally when I feel like it when I
don't like to phone it in and it was a
doctor who saved a lot of lives heal the
sick you got to go together
what does Ken Jeong really me
I think to be Ken Jong is to enjoy life
to savor it to not think at all
and when you do anything in your career
so many people overthink not this guy I
just do I trust my instincts but I trust
my impulses more I don't think when I do
any career move and that is why I'm here
on wired autocomplete and you better
believe baby what's what's it gonna be
Ken Jong Wow this is a deep cut thank
you
this means a lot to me one of my best
friends Mike O'Connell wrote this song
and we did it on Funny or Die in YouTube
that went viral this is like almost 12
years ago and it was a song that he
wrote called what's it gonna be it's
kind of one of my favorite things I ever
did I was hired on the movie Step
Brothers with Will Ferrell and Adam
McKay because of the popularity of that
video and here's a sample was it gonna
be good okay does Ken Jeong speak
Spanish
we not really I think that might be a
Google question because I play senior
Ben Chang on community for six years
part of the hallmark of that character
was that he was never a licensed Spanish
professor and he himself was teaching
Spanish that he learned from Sesame
Street
so acting does Ken Jeong speak Korean
that is because I am of Korean descent
my Korean is not very good you know I
can speak a little bit under my father
did make me go to a Korean language
school when I was a kid ken Jeong speaks
a little bit like I'm gonna say uh means
hello
come sunny da and that's it does Ken
Jeong dance that is a resounding yes
every talk show every media appearance I
do ken Jeong dances the same four moves
over and over and over again until it
annoys the world and then there's a
post-ironic embrace and then I be
loved would you like me to dance no okay
does Ken Jeong have a brother
no I do not actually I have a sister her
name is Sarah hi you're on wired
autocomplete and you're welcome I'm
barely mentioning your names because I
am a for attention okay Ken Jeong
did you die that is because in hangover
2 the character I'm best known for mr.
Chow always says but did you die we're
gonna fact I had to do jury duty it was
a murder trial it really does suck when
the defendant recognizes you at that
murder trial so when he's looking at his
lawyer he goes oh snap but did you die
I'm like okay no I'm awesome sidebar
your honor excuse please
so we are completing of this portion and
I'll just hold this in perpetuity love
it good
where does Ken Jeong mm-hmm live that is
a celebrity secret I can't tell you that
I live in Oak Park California on three
one one driveway Lane come on by where
did dr. ken Jeong work that's a great
question I actually was a licensed
physician and I worked at Kaiser
Permanente an HMO for about seven years
and that's where I met my wife who also
worked at Kaiser Permanente so it's a
good question
where did Ken Jeong go to go to high
school I went to Paige high school in
Greensboro North Carolina and we were
best known as the page pirates and we
were the state for a champs in my 10th
11th and 12th grade in football and we
were city high IQ quiz bowl champ in my
junior year of which I was the go-to
math guy you heard it here first wired
of stuff you don't care about and that
is it for Wired
auto-complete I am Ken Jeong and I
really appreciate you having me can I go
now